hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer as
always i've been challenged to take a
common food
and make it fancy today's rules are
you must use the food a given you can
only up to the food
you can buy whatever ingredients you
wish okay let's see what we are making
fancy today
drum rolls
candy tuna surprisingly for this show
i've had candle tina a lot of times i
like
canned tuna especially if it's in olive
oil
so good call getting one i like the one
with like
light chunk in water i feel like it's
too dry
and it doesn't have any good flavor so
canned tuna has
both strong smell and a strong flavor so
in order to make it fancy i have to dial
down
both smell and flavor even though i like
it i haven't had it for a long time so
i want to try this it's just like a cat
food
[Music]
i like it this is a little bit drier
than i remember
so i want to make texture a little bit
better i want to add some variety
and i want to make it prettier because
people
also eat with eyes and that it's going
to be
most challenging part i think okay i've
got some great ideas and i'm so excited
to
make it fancy
okay here's what i got rice japanese
mayo
radish salmon raw chives cucumber
serrano pepper avocado and caviar
from the pantry i got sugar steamy
pepper
rice vinegar sesame oil chili oil
soy sauce meringue and sriracha
and one more thing i got
magnum side sake
let's get started make it fancy
so when you are making this dish you
want to make sure to choose show grain
rice
so it's easy to shape one
and two cups i want to wash this rice
and i'll be right back rice is washed
i'm adding a little bit less water than
usual
so i'm using two cups of water soak rice
for
20 to 30 minutes but for now i'm going
on to next step
i'm going to make vinaigrette one
tablespoon of sugar
one teaspoon salt and a quarter cup
of rice vinegar just combine everything
together
and mix well until salt and sugar
dissolves
it's good my vinaigrette is done we are
going to use this later
so time for candle tuna slice some
chives
save a few for later you just want to
chop
like very finely you don't want to have
a big chunk of chives
into a bowl can of tuna gonna drain a
little bit
oil this looks like cat food i
used to be a cat person but i did a
cassetting
for my friend and the cats goes crazy at
night
they torn the curtain like whenever i
move my feet
they try to attack it and i go scared
i'm adding japanese mayo if you don't
have japanese mine you can use regular
mayo but this
is what i like half tablespoon of
sriracha
one teaspoon of chili oil and
one teaspoon of sesame oil start with
pinch of salt and steamy pepper this
is japanese peppers jimmy means like
seven spices
it's not as spicy as cayenne pepper but
it kind of has a nice cake and chives
mix all it up sesame oil kind of
mask the smell of candle tuna
which is very nice and i want to taste
it
did i look like a kombucha girl like
girls
sleep kombucha she was like
i think it's a little bit more so but
overall it's
nice it's a little bit spicy and tastes
good
cup of it's plastic and keep in the
refrigerator until i use it
next i'm going to make sauce 2 tbsp
of soy sauce i use sake a lot for my
japanese cooking
so someone very considerate call me a
magnum side socket
and it's very difficult to pour
one tablespoon i feel like i got a
little bit more but
that's hard and also if you're shopping
meeping
make sure to get home meaning it's in
japanese
there is one called aji mirin don't buy
that
that it's just corn syrup usually it
contains alcohol this one
is eight percent alcohol three percent
it's nothing
whenever i buy sake or wine they ask me
id
but whenever i buy mirroring they never
ask
so the reason i'm boiling this up one
is make the sauce thicker and also
evaporating alcohol so it's not
too strong or it's safe to eat for
underage people
it's thickens because miring and sake
has a sugar content
so it kind of become a syrupy texture i
think it's good
my sauce is done and i'm going to next
step
so rice is cooked and i'm going to mix
the vinaigrette
i recommend to dip with water so it
doesn't stick too much
rice stands out very nice so when you're
making sushi rice it's important to mix
the
vinegar mixture when rice is still hot
i'm adding little by little so it will
mix
nicely rice is seasoned i'm going to
shape this like a little bowl
i recommend you to dip your hands and
shape it so it doesn't
stick your hand one portion is like two
tablespoons
maybe size of golf ball but it's
different
shape kind of shaping with your palm
like kind of cook your hands and
push top you don't want to squeeze too
much because
you don't want to eat mushy rice
this is not perfectly round i think they
are cute enough
okay i've got my rice balls i'm on to
next step
so i heated up oil for 350 and i'm going
to
fry rice ball i just made this is not
traditional japanese
sushi at all this is something i had
when i moved to l.a
and it was really good so i want to
recreate that
i'm doing four at the time and make sure
it has uh each space between it
otherwise it's gonna stick together and
it's kind of become
sushi centerpiece what i'm looking for
is golden brown
color because rice is already cooked you
don't need to worry about
if it's cooking through so just wanted
to make sure
everything is nice and golden brown when
you are kind of new to frying
you will be a little bit scared oil
splashing but
that's kind of happens and it's not that
bad
you get used to it it's painful
just like for a second but it doesn't
last that long
just like you know when you break up
your heart aches
for a bit and you will get used to it it
will get better
okay so this looks great nice color look
like giant tater tots
i'm going to try it
nice crunch outside or inside it's still
soft rice
okay on to the next step i got my
vegetables and i'm going to start with
avocado
just cut in half and squeeze
lemon so avocado change color season
with salt
i'm gonna mash it up so avocado is done
set aside i'm gonna need a few radish
take off the stem
and i'm gonna use mandarin slicer if you
don't have it you can just
use knife soak in the water so it
doesn't dry out
and i'm using like here instead of
slicing with finger
when you slip it i feel like good chunk
of finger will be gone
but if you're using this part it's like
less damage
on your hand cooking in a kitchen it's
like a battlefield
you have like bottle scars everywhere
serrano pepper
the pepper like jalapeno serrano any
kind of pepper
the spicy powdered seeds and this white
part
called piss if you don't like spicy just
remove that part
and you're good to go and set those
aside and a cucumber
cut it kind of long shape you can use
mandarin
that i used earlier or you can use
peeler
for long ribbons okay i've got all my
vegetables ready
i'm gonna start with this rice you use
cucumber
wrap around it cucumber it's a little
bit wet so
it kind of sticks perfectly soy sauce
avocado
spicy tuna i have radish
topped with caviar
finish with chives one done
before i play i want to put this sweet
soy underneath it
so it kind of gives a nice presentation
sweet soy
cucumber avocado
[Music]
spicy tuna
samurai just design your own
sushi and saran pepper and we are done
very fancy welcome jasmine for
making fancy jasmine hosts this show
called
giant food time so this is opposite of
giant food tiny food time can you guess
what i made fancy from
canned tuna yes so fancy looking
yeah do you like candy tuna i love candy
okay
some people doesn't like it i like it a
lot of people don't like it because they
say it's too fishy but that's kind of
what i like about it
do you have a name for this dish you can
name do you want a name
i see tuna time fixation okay
what pretty sexy you think oh everything
look at this glaze
it's like so scrumptious you know
you just look at it and you're like that
weird
yes okay jasmine have fun with this
okay
[Music]
so fancy so delicious make it fussy
good kali welcome to make it fancy
oh i'm so excited you know i love to eat
so this is perfect yay
it definitely looks really fancy to me i
love detail i love art so i love like
the brush
look like the stroke of the sauce at the
bottom because i'm like that's a lot of
um
detail pick your favorite would you
recommend eating it in one whole bite or
bite by bite i think bye bye bye
because it's quite big okay yeah i'll
catch it i think anything
oh my god this is delicious thank you
thank you so much for watching and let
us know why you want me to make fancy
next time
don't forget to dance make it fancy
bye